i'm proud to be british by the same time
more so i'm proud to be black
[Music]
i've always identified myself as proudly
british and
proudly west african all my life i
straddled the two
cultures you can be both you don't have
to be exclusively one thing
and perhaps it's because i become a dad
for the first time but recently
i've been thinking a lot about my
identity
what does it mean to be black and
british
being cold that's what it means what are
my own
personal connections with a country like
sierra leone a country
where my mother's from and what part
should all of that play
in my son's life so you sneak dog
he's got some good tunes play some when
you're a bit older
sometimes instead of potato i might
separate it
and sometimes instead of potato i can
say potato c
you will find media somewhere between
black british and a british civil union
[Music]
the creoles are people who were
resettled by the british
the creoles are the group many of my
family descend from
this exhibition tells their story bronze
island was one of the
key places where they would it was like
a holding place
for all this you know slaves the creoles
are an
ethnic group descended from the first
settlers since sierra leone by the
british
including london's black poor and those
freed from illegal slave ships
after the abolition of the slave trade
in 1807.
you then had african-americans who
helped
the british they fought on the side of
the british during the american
revolutionary war the british promised
freedom if they fought
on their side but by far
the most number comes from people called
liberated africans
these were people on their way to
slavery when the slave trade was
abolished
my mother told me about how her
grandmother's
mother was on a ship from the new world
traveling back to west africa that was
being escorted by the british
she remembers being only person that
didn't have
any chains on her or any ropes on her
and she's going around this boat giving
the other people water sierra leone has
strong ties with britain throughout its
history
and it's where my grandfather founded
the country's first school for blind
children
for which amongst other endeavors he was
knighted by the queen
in 1971. close ties with britain was a
source of pride for many sierra leoneans
and those
strong links saw many my family included
settle in the uk after decolonization
[Music]
today their children and their
grandchildren are british
and governments data reveals there are
almost two million
black britons living in the uk each with
their own
unique experience of what it means to be
black and british
somewhere between a londoner and a
freight onion
somewhere between waterloo junction and
waterloo station
buying casada bread before i open the
london eye see
you'll find me there sis
how do you identify yourself this is my
sister and my cousins
growing up our parents made sure our
west african heritage
was a big part of our lives when i was
younger i felt more african than i did
british
i think as i've grown up and i'm older i
found a balance
being black british i think it's to
break it down into three aspects
if you look at culture the stories that
your parents tell you the food that you
eat
cow food and the chocolate the music
that they listen to
going to family gatherings it's
something that just runs through you
i'm proud to be a single psychologist
but singularity
and english in science it's down to
uh responsibility responsibility for my
actions the way i carry myself
the way i treat my family we know how
we've benefited
by being able to carry on our culture
tradition that sense of identity
and i think there's a responsibility
mazzy's point there is a responsibility
for us to pass it on to the next
generation white people
they do their culture and friday chips
and food and fish
so our food on friday we have fish
and akara and planting and then lastly i
would say
it's about pride i first say i am
african i'm west african
i happen to be born for me in in
the u.s and have been educated in the uk
um all of which i am fiercely proud of
um but for me i think my heartland is
always back home
when people ask me oh so so twiggy where
are you from
oh yeah i come from sierra leone i think
that's the first day we landed
twiggy went to sierra leone for the
first time last year and wrote about her
experience for vogue magazine
of course i'm british but i say yes
sierra leone oh when's the last time you
went back
nothing to say i say oh i've never
actually been before and they're like oh
why didn't you go back me and a friend
of mine
um we just came to the resolution that
we just we need to go back
me near the near the sierra leone hut
we need to be able to say to people that
we know that we've actually been sierra
leone before and to actually know a lot
more about ourselves
the sky looks absolutely amazing
it's stunning yeah it really is
the last year saw 400 000 people leave
the uk
to build a new life abroad among them
many
young black britons returning to the
countries their parents and grandparents
left years ago
they say there are opportunities in
africa that don't exist here
it was january 19 2019
i went to heathrow got in a plane and
never
never turned back africa has been in
sierra leone for a year now
she sees it as a country of opportunity
moving back to sierra leone was kind of
like in the moment
thing i studied migration development
um very long degree so i'll just break
it down to migration development
and the market for that in the uk
was just non-existent so it just made
more sense to go and work in the place
that most of my study and you know
passions were
rooted in
people are you know starting to realize
that you know
that there's more out there than
the west for a community for in progress
for a free time so i'd be interested to
get your thoughts on
what a country like sierra leone would
have to offer
our generation yvonne lived in the uk
for years before moving back to sierra
leone and becoming the mayor of freetown
she's also my cousin this our home
has been deprived of so much colonialism
created its own level of
weakening of our infrastructure
our societies our norms our institutions
and painting this picture gamal because
i want
you to refrain that question africa is
not going to
offer you we need to come and take it
and make it somewhere between safe and
sound
and barely sounding safe somewhere
between two homes yet still feeling
homeless
spending too long in one home when does
it fall in boat
you'll find me there you know we need
talented people from here to go there to
help the economy to help the society to
help everything else i think it's a
positive step but it's not necessarily
the right step for everyone
after spending my three months in sierra
leone i realized the
importance of my britishness as much as
we don't want to discuss it
the country is still run by
neocolonialism the lifestyle is
completely
different to what i'm accustomed to in
the uk so i think i'll find it very hard
adapting but one thing that really i can
get used to
internet access i know it's a first
world problem
but being a filmmaker i need to be
glued to the online world i will achieve
a lot more for sierra leone being
in the diaspora than actually being in
sierra leone
so you'll find me there in search of a
cotton tree
in the center of london it is quite
different
living in sierra leone compared to
london i think i just felt this sense of
just peace we landed and we just heard
everyone speak in korea and we turned to
each other we're like
we're actually here somewhere speaking
english with an african accent one of
the things that struck me is that
everybody sort of looked like me it was
the same color like you you weren't
you know you weren't one out of a
handful of a handful of people it just
felt very safe and i was just like oh
so this is what it feels like to to not
feel like an other
a centena created talk with in it in its
accent
2020 has seen the covert 19 pandemic and
the black lives matter protests
really shine a light on some of the
inequalities and disparities that exist
in society it's led to young people
calling for change they're in a hurry to
make that happen now
the momentum needs to keep on going it
needs to keep on going and we
definitely need more black people in
higher positions it's the
the covert racism that for me is
still very much intertwined in our
day-to-day and that's the bit that
i would love to see sort of uncovered
and
spoken about and addressed we've got to
be really really conscious and that
means trying to find
talented young black kids helping them
to see that they could be anything they
can do anything
i've benefited from both worlds i'm
british and have been grounded in west
african culture
ultimately it's not up to me to decide
how my son identifies himself
but it is important that he's proud and
mindful of his heritage
the rest i'll leave to him
he can make his own choices
doesn't it
you